ses portraits en noir et blanc fait le
tour du monde
le centre charles péguy expose une série
de portraits du britannique leigh
jeffries lumière et cros plan évoque le
19e siècle industriel et la misère de sa
classe ouvrière dans le bassin houiller
mais non ces clichés publiés en 2016
sont des photos des laissés pour compte
de nos sociétés contemporaines
des visages abîmé des masses al lid
jeffries à capter surtout la force
l'intensité de leur regard quand le noir
devient source de lumière politique
j'essaie son titre est un tableau de
pierre soulages l'un des plus grands
peintres français encore vivants pour
apprécier les contrastes rendu par les
aplats de pigments noirs
il faut se promener le long du tableau
se pencher son extraire un vrai voyage
dans ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler
l'outrenoir
le grand format près du musée d'art
moderne de paris est exposée au musée
des beaux arts d'orléans
jusqu'au 6 janvier 2019 on termine avec
l'exposition de la plasticienne
charlotte de maupéou à la collégiale
saint piat le pull et elle peint sur du
bois de la toile de jute du carton des
formats plus ou moins grand quel travail
au sol
quand on est au sol on n'a pas du tout
la même appréhension le show wallemme
fait complètement paniqué alors qu'au
sol en inondant ça va effrayer on bouge
tout d'un coup le tableau se rétrécit
énormément charlotte de maupéou peint
des portraits des autoportraits des
tableaux de peintres célèbres revisités
ou ré interpréter comme celui de vermeer
as manet ou courbet
[Musique]